oh the oscars last night i watched it
the whole thing
yep you stay up late you watched the ask
it is my favorite day of the year
even when i was a little kid i loved the
oscars and my mom bought me an old like
red towel at the thrift store and she
would put it on a front porch and an
oscar sunday i would always like stand
on it and she would take my picture on
the camera we had to wind it
do you remember i just love oscar sunday
the glamour all of it i live for it oh
well you know i love the history of the
academy awards
and the outfits the films
um i think looking back is what makes me
love
the oscars today but we're following up
that big glamorous night with a big
beautiful story this morning pop sugar
report
that beauty products are going waterless
what okay so check this out i know
because i said the same thing brands are
taking out the water
and giving you dry goods instead
shampoo bars dry moisturizers
and body wash powder so this is this is
okay i i was like your shampoo and this
is your body wash which i have to say
like
i was a oh dear i was a big borax girl
like remember we used to put your hands
in the thing and do that does everybody
remember that
and i missed that i love scrubbing with
the granules so i'm feeling
this um um at first i was like h2omg i
don't know how i feel about this
like what are you talking about but i
it's actually good if you're traveling
imagine you're camping or something
i don't know maybe it's a stretch i just
kind of like soap is that too much to
ask for
you know what though for traveling
because you can't
trap it's open so every time you make a
point you're like
i'm like when you travel it's great
because you can't bring water by the way
this company
also has nip a nipple and areola stick
what do you do i didn't realize that
that was a thing
it's like chapstick for your name all
right well next we've got
news from vogue about a beautiful new
jewelry collaboration you're going to
love this fashion brand
private policy and artist chella mann
have teamed up to create a special line
of ear jewelry
to celebrate the deaf and the hard of
hearing communities
chella has dealt with hearing devices
since childhood and his designs are
meant to accentuate
and honor the hearing aids and hearing
implants and this was launched for
national deaf history month and get this
50 of profits go to the deaf queer
resource center yes and they're so
beautiful right
i think they are absolute works of art
it's artistic it has depth and meaning
it's celebrating something it's
philanthropic
um just i love it i love it too and when
i see somebody wearing one of those like
with your hair up and you sort of turn
and you have that moment it's stunning
so if you've never
worn one give it a shot well finally you
know we we love to turn to tick tock to
solve life's
little problems and um today we've got
an incredible tik-tok hack that's
supposed to solve an age-old problem
we've all been there
how do you chop an onion without crying
like a maniac
drew have you been in the kitchen just
having a moment with your tears
chewing gum helps but i've never had gum
around because i don't like chewing gum
i hear lighting uh a candle or a match
helps
but for how long well i'm gonna do light
the match over and over and over again i
don't know i'm not scientist drew that's
why i turned to tick-tock
they say they say well the secret is
it wants to go to moisture right so if
you lay a damp
paper towel next to your cutting board
it absorbs the chemical in the onion
that makes you cry before it hits your
peepers
that's what they say and so we have here
a wet paper towel
and some onions so do you want to chop
away it is wet
yeah so i don't know if this is going to
work but this is this would change my
life if it did because i
hate that when i do i feel like i'm
about to lose a finger don't you dare
don't you dare
i know it's it's not stable i'm just
telling you
hold on i have to say my face is right
here in it and i'm not crying at all i
mean
hold on let me take off my glasses look
nothing no tears nothing
yeah i have to say like i mean maybe
it's the nipple bomb but
something is working over here
maybe it's the wet paper towel i have to
say
i think this is really working yeah
because i'm seriously not getting any
tears
i'm getting a tiny whiff in my peepers
but
nothing compared to what i usually feel
like which is like
you know so are you gonna try this next
time you're cooking are you gonna
literally do it okay i'm totally gonna
do it this is a game changer i think i
am too
i mean nothing that's amazing
you